give me a son and I shall make you the
greatest King ever Beowulf from a
technological standpoint is so perfect
for imax 3d the precision in detail
which the filmmakers use to make the
movie is so conducive to the imax 3d
experience 3d has been designed in imax
to be experienced at the bridge of your
nose which is why when you watch a movie
in imax you're constantly reaching or
grabbing or ducking and that's because
the 3d is literally a first-person you
are in the movie experience
the whole idea of imax 3d is the
audience is not just looking at through
a window at a 3d world are an image on a
flat screen but actually is immersed in
the action that's taking place in the
movie for beowulf we have the
opportunity to take a selection of shots
and enhance them to take full advantage
of the range of that that's only
available in imax 3d theaters to do this
we use set of tools that were originally
developed for our recent 2d to 3d
projects but work just as well
increasing the depth of the 3d that
already exists in Beowulf what we've
done is use those tools to expand the
depth range expander the 3d experience
and bring certain characters and objects
even closer to the audience imax 3d
takes advantage of the sheer size and
mammoth size of our screens it's able to
utilize the sound that our system
provides which is up to 14,000 watts of
digital surround sound and with images
that are immersive and first-person
you're literally brought inside the
movie in imax 3d this movie looks and
sounds amazing in items and we have no
doubt that people are going to
absolutely love it she's not like us I
mean